- You look beautiful.
- Well...
- I love this.
Oh, what's happening?
- I feel like a competition winner.
I've been the biggest fan
and I feel like I have
manipulated an acting career
and a BAFTA just so I
could get close to you.
(audience applauds)
I feel like,
yeah and finally its worked!
- Its worked my plan!
- You are God stunning.
Your blue eyes, with your dark hair
and like snow white skin.
Like wow!
- Oh my God.
- You're stunning. Yeah.
I was just saying.
- A bit obsessed Kelly.
Back off.
- I was looking at your eyes,
you look like one of those
beautiful wolves, you know,
like have the...
- Oh my God. Thanks.
- Yeah.
- And I didn't even have time
to do any professional
hair and makeup as well.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I woke up like this as well.
This is no weave at all.
(audience laughs)
Yes.
- Isn't it embarrassing
to be this gorgeous when you wake up?
(Kelly laughs)
It's so embarrassing.
- It's so rude.
(audience applauds)
- Can I tell you something?
I had a memory (indistinct),
like I cannot tell you
what of a big fan I am,
if it's not coming across
from my vibes anyways,
my stalker-ish vibes.
But I had a memory resurface
recently as a sort of like,
oh God, please let this
never make the press!
So now I feel like I'm
getting ahead of it.
(audience laughs)
- Okay. I like this.
I do this.
- This is sort of, this is PR management.